bonjour à tous le mâle existe-t-il le
mâle existe-t-il
bon c'est une question qui ne date pas
d'hier
on sait que socrate disait le mal n'est
rien pour socrate c'était le roi de
l'ironie évidemment quand il disait que
le mal n'était rien il fallait
comprendre
autre chose il fallait essayer de le
décaler son esprit pour essayer de
comprendre ce qu'il voulait dire
mais d'une certaine manière il y a du
sens dans cette phrase le mal n'est rien
et c'est sur cette question que
j'aimerais réfléchir à votre aujourd'hui
notamment à travers un philosophe
malheureusement assez peu connu du grand
public qui est line its limits est connu
pour son ouvrage et c2 théodicée la
théodicée c'est l'analyse et l'étude des
propriétés de dieu et notamment de la
question de l'existence du mal sur terre
autorisé par dieu dans la perse
de l'amx dieu existe c'est un fait pour
lui et donc il faut prendre en compte ce
présupposé évidemment dans une société
laïcisé c'est un présupposé qui est un
peu coûteux mais on va faire l'effort de
jouer le jeu de partir du principe que
dieu existe
si on admet que dieu existe alors
forcément à un moment donné se pose la
question alors pourquoi le mâle
existe-t-il
alors qu'est ce qu'on appelle le mal
vient le mal ce sont les guerres qui tue
des civils innocents
le mal ce sont les maladies les virus
qui tue également des innocents
le mal c'est l'injustice c'est tout ce
qui fait souffrir des personnes qui
n'ont pas mérité cette souffrance c'est
ça le mal et le fait est que le mal
existe je le fait est que des gens
souffrent sans avoir était coupable de
méfait le mal touche des innocents et
c'est d'ailleurs ce à la définition du
mal c'est qu'il s'en prend aux faibles
et aux innocents mais la mipps ne nie
pas que le mal existe à proprement
parler mais simplement il essaye de le
comprendre et de l'expliquer la
théodicée de la mitsva consistait à
comprendre comment le mal peut exister
dans un monde créé par dieu dieu étant
défini comme un être parfait naître
omnipotent et un être bienveillant
comment peut-il autorisé comment peut-il
seulement accepté que le mâle puisse
exister ces sept
si on entre on les propriétés que l'on
prête à dieu et l'existence du mal qui
fait que la mitsva s'interroger sur
cette question qui est une grande
question de la théologie
comment le mâle peut-il exister dans un
monde créé par dieu
c'est d'ailleurs une des objections
qu'on fait souvent aux croyants
notamment aux croyants religieux en leur
disant mais si votre dieu est si parfait
il peut tout qu'il connaît tous et qu'il
est bon pourquoi les styles les
personnes se faire massacrer
pourquoi les styles des maladies tuer
des innocents catastrophes naturelles
pourquoi et la question est légitime
seulement la mx relève que lorsqu'on
pose cette question
on n'est pas attentif à quelque chose de
très important qui est ce qu'on pourrait
appeler la relativité du mal qu'est ce
que c'est que la relativité du mal bien
leibniz l'expliquent assez simplement il
nous dit que le problème de l'être
humain c'est qu'il est un un
hypersensible du mal un hypersensible de
la souffrance remarque
ce qui ne va pas on remarque la
souffrance on remarque les injustices
mais on ne remarque pas toutes les fois
où le mal n'est pas là on ne remarque
pas toutes les fois où tout va bien vous
savez lorsqu'on est malade qu'on chope
une bonne grippe ou une bonne gastro
tout à coup on en vit le moment où on
n'était pas malade
on a l'impression que ce moment où on
était en pleine santé ce moment où ne
souffrait pas était un moment
merveilleux et c'est seulement quand on
souffre c'est seulement quand on est
malade ou quand on est malheureux qu'on
prend conscience du bonheur qu'on
ressent quand on n'est pas malade ou
quand il n'y a pas de problème on est
attentif à ce qui ne va pas mais d'un
point de vue rationnel
ce n'est pas logique on devrait
finalement d'un point de vue rationnel
mettre dans la balance
tous les moments où ça va et tous les
moments où ça ne va pas et alors on
s'apercevrait de quelque chose
d'absolument déterminant c'est que les
moments où ça va sont bien plus nombreux
que les moments où ça ne va pas j'avais
une vidéo où je parlais du fait que la
réflexion à outrance la cogitation
excessive et pathologique pouvait nous
amener à créer des problèmes à partir de
rien nous sommes très capables nous
autres êtres humains de créer du malheur
à partir de rien et écartelé que je cite
dans ma vidéo
il a cette phrase à la fois extrêmement
simple et pleine de bon sens qui est de
dire si vous vous posez la question de
qu'est ce qui ne va pas là maintenant
vous allez être
embarrassée parce qu'en réalité là
maintenant il n'y a pas de problème il
n'y a pas de problème là maintenant le
problème est toujours une anticipation
d'un mâle futur et lorsque le problème
se présente à nous lorsqu'il devient
notre présent on n'a plus le temps de le
mentaliser on n'a plus le temps de le
penser comme problème on doit le gérer
si vous vous baladez dans la forêt que
tout à coup vous voyez un sanglier qui
surgit sur vous est-ce que vous pensez
que vous aurez le temps de vous dire
tiens là il ya un problème c'est votre
corps qui va comprendre qu'il ya un
problème
c'est votre corps qui va éventuellement
enfuir c'est votre corps qui va réagir
si bien que votre esprit à ce moment là
est en veille il n'a plus rien à dire
or le problème est une notion mental
c'est une projection de l'esprit qui
correspond à l'anticipation d'un mâle
futur donc le mal est d'abord un produit
du mental c'est d'abord une projection
de l'esprit et c'est quelque chose qu'on
vit totalement différemment selon qu on
le projette selon qu'on l'envisagent et
selon qu'on le vit c'était pas pareil
d'anticiper un problème et de le vivre
la relativité du mal c'est le fait que
la plupart de nos maux sont liées au
fait que nous ne sommes pas attentifs au
bien
nous ne sommes pas attentifs à tout ce
qui va à tout ce qui fonctionne et à
tout ce qui nous rend heureux
ce avec beaucoup de personnes qui ont
souffert d'une maladie et en ont guéri
ou deux personnes qui ont traversé des
épreuves très difficiles les souffrances
et qui finalement ont réussi à s'en
sortir bien ces personnes là ont une
autre approche de la vie notre manière
d'appréhender le bonheur pour ces
personnes-là un rien peut suffire à les
rendre heureux comme si l'expérience du
mal avait produit sur eux une sorte de
réveil de la sensibilité au bien et au
bonheur
comme si finalement il fallait traverser
des épreuves et souffrir pour se rendre
compte que tout compte fait la vie c'est
plutôt pas mal
les injustices existe et c'est un fait
que la miss ne nie pas d'ailleurs à ce
propos
petite parenthèse leibniz c'est pas glop
chez voltaire dans son conte
philosophique candidats pour ceux qui
l'ont lu en glace c'est le philosophe de
l'optimisme c'est celui qui trouve
toujours le moyen de dire que finalement
tout va bien finalement tout n'est pas
si mal et nous vivons après tout dans le
meilleur des mondes possibles
voltaire a voulu caricaturer la pensée
de la mite ce qu'ils disaient que tout
bien considéré le mal n'est pas si grave
vol car avait écrit un poème sur le
désastre de lisbonne que je vous invite
à lire ou il ironisait sur la pensée de
la mise en insistant bien sur le fait
que parfois la mort et la souffrance
touche des innocents et qu'on ne peut
pas fermer les yeux sur ces injustices
sauf que la miss ne ferme pas les yeux
la mx
ouvre les yeux justement et nous invite
à ouvrir les yeux sur le bien j'ai
intitulé cette vidéo le mal n'existe pas
c'était évidemment une provocation
c'était une manière de caricaturer la
liste comme le fait voltaire car la miss
ne pense pas que le mal n'existe pas
mais il pense que le mal est une
condition pour accéder au bien je
parlais tout à l'heure de la relativité
du mal la relativité du mal c'est de
dire que nous ne percevons le mal que
parce que nous avons connaissance du
bien et c'est parce que nous avons
éprouvé le mal que nous pouvons
percevoir le bien mais il ya une autre
manière d'entendre l'expression de
relativité du mal l'autre manière c'est
de dire que le mal est toujours en en
quelques manières une étape vers le bien
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire l'encan
est ce qu'on n'est pas encore dans le
discours habituel qu'on entend parfois
chez ces spiritualiste ou chez ces
mystiques béa pour qui il faut tout
accepter au nom de l'amour universel et
du lâcher prise et se dire que après
tout tout a un sens
donc le mal a un sens oui en quelque
sorte oui en quelque sorte
mais la question est de savoir est-ce
que c'est faux c'est ce qu'il est faux
de dire que le mal est souvent un mal
pour un bien
est ce qu'il faut de dire que le mal est
parfois nécessaire pour accéder à une
forme de biens et là on se
embêté parce que généralement en bas
c'est le cas ce sont nos échecs ce sont
nos souffrances ce sont nos malheurs qui
nous permettent de comprendre les causes
et les origines de cette souffrance ou
de ce malheur le mal nous donne toujours
une leçon et cette leçon dès lors qu'on
est conscient et qu'on la met en
pratique nous permet ensuite de ne pas
retomber dans l'erreur donc dans la
souffrance et dans le malheur nietzsche
disait que ce qui ne nous tue pas nous
rend plus fort c'est une manière imagée
assez simple et en même temps assez
parlante de traduire ce que disait la
mise à propos du mal lorsque nous sommes
atteints par un virus pour prendre un
exemple au hasard
nous fabriquons des anticorps et ces
anticorps nous permettront de lutter
contre le virus si jamais il venait à se
représenter à nous c'est un mal pour un
bien
vous savez que quand on se fracturé un
os il se reconsolider de telle manière
qui devient beaucoup plus solide
qu'avant c'est un mal pour un bien
dans beaucoup de situations de notre vie
nous agissons et ne nous trompons nous
faisons erreurs et nous échouerons mais
pour peu qu'on se montre attentif à nos
erreurs bien il est fort possible que
notre erreur se transforme en leçon qui
nous permettra ensuite de ne pas
reproduire l'erreur c'est un mal pour un
bien
un mal pour un
n'est pas qu'une expression un mal pour
un bien
c'est le constat que le mal a toujours
une double face la phase subjective et
immédiate qui est la souffrance
et puis la phase objective et qui ne
déploie ses effets que dans le temps qui
est l'apprentissage le mal nous apprend
des choses
combien parmi nous se sont laissés
abuser manipuler blessé par d'autres et
en auront tiré les enseignements de
nature à les immuniser contre de
nouvelles attaques
il ne s'agit pas de dire que cette
souffrance est une bonne chose
en tant que souffrance il s'agit de dire
que cette souffrance est une bonne chose
comme moyens en vue d'une autre fin en
vue d'une fin qui est l'évolution
personnelle
c'est ça la fonction du mal pour la miss
nous aider à progresser tous que
son mal nous enseigne à faire le bien
l'erreur est une nécessité pédagogique
l'erreur c'est ce que l'on corrige et on
ne peut pas corriger notre comportement
si on ne fait pas d'erreur alors
certains diront mais on peut très bien
faire le bien
sans être passé par le mal on peut très
bien avoir un sens inné pour le bien et
la vertu oui sauf que celui qui est
passé par le mal ou celui qui est passé
par l'erreur une fois qu'il en sort il a
conscience de ce qu'est le mal il a
conscience de ce qu'est l'erreur et donc
il a beaucoup moins de chance de
reproduire cette erreur que celui qui
n'est tout simplement pas passer par
l'erreur d'ailleurs il faut faire la
distinction entre l'erreur et la faute
erreur c'est ce que nous commettons tous
lorsque nous nous trompons de bonne foi
la faute c'est lorsque nous reproduisons
cette erreur en ayant conscience que
c'est une erreur l'erreur est humaine
persévérer dans l'erreur est diabolique
la faute c'est la persévérance dans
l'erreur
on peut perdre
dans l'erreur est tombé dans la faute on
peut donc reproduire nos erreurs et
reproduire le mal mais à ce moment là ce
n'est pas le mal en lui-même qui est en
cause c'est notre incapacité à avoir
conscience de ce mal c'est notre
incapacité à le reconnaître comme mal et
dans ce cas là nous sommes les
responsables il n'ya pas invoquer dieu
pour justifier ou pour comprendre nos
propres manquements il n'y a pas à faire
porter le chapeau à dieu de nos erreurs
parce que si dieu nous a créés et
faillible si dieu nous a créés un
parfait et ça ne veut pas dire que nous
ne soyons pas capables de nous réformer
d'évoluer et de progresser
si dieu a créé le mal c'est pour nous
pousser aux biens
c'est pour nous pousser à surpasser le
mal qui est en nous ce qui suppose d'en
avoir conscience
le mal serait donc l'outil qui permet à
l'homme parce qu'il a une conscience de
se transformer et de tendre vers le bien
jusqu'à atteindre le mal n'est rien
non pas parce que le mal n'existe pas
mais parce que le mal n'est que le
produit de l'oeuvre humaines sont les
hommes qui crée le mal et les hommes
pourraient décider
il pourrait décréter de ne pas faire le
mal
si les hommes font le mal c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas encore tiré toutes les leçons
du mal je prendre un exemple j'ai fait
de la boxe
et quand on veut
la boxe on prend des pins dans la gueule
donc on a mal et c'est jamais très
agréable de prendre des pins dans la
tronche même quand on a une mentalité de
bagarreur seulement voilà quand on prend
des coups dans la figure
il arrive un moment où on a plus envie
d'en prendre donc à ce qu'on fait ben on
apprend à esquiver
on apprend à contrer on apprend
anticipées on apprend à minimiser le mal
on apprend à éviter le mal et quand on
fait de la boxe généralement ben n'a pas
envie de se battre dans la vie de tous
les jours
alors on sait qu'on peut on sait qu'on
peut faire face à une agression c'est
vrai nom n'aime pas se battre au sens où
la conscience que prendre des coups dans
la gueule ça fait mal et on n'a pas
envie de le faire subir à un autre même
s'il a bien mérité parfois l'expérience
du mal ne donne pas envie de refaire
l'expérience du mal et c'est ça le
message philosophique de l'anis c'est de
dire que l'expérience du mal conduit à
la connaissance du mal et la
connaissance du mal ne nous donne pas
envie de rester en présence du mal alors
certes parfois l'enseignement est long
et laborieux
il faut du temps avant de comprendre
qu'on a fait le mal et qu'on ne souhaite
plus le faire généralement ce qui se
produit c'est que ont su
soi même les conséquences du mal dont on
est l'auteur on finit par se dire que
cette mauvaise idée et qu'on ferait
mieux de faire autre chose que le mâle
est dès lors qu'on est conscient dès
lors qu'on est attentif aux conséquences
de nos actions mais généralement on
cherche à éviter le mal on cherche à ne
pas le reproduire
tout simplement parce que l'homme de
manière naturelle a tendance à fuir le
mal c'est à dire à fuir ce qui le fait
souffrir
alors c'est vrai que parfois on
s'autorise à faire souffrir les autres
et c'est seulement quand on souffre soi
même qu'on se pose la question du mal
c'est vrai mais il est tout aussi vrai
que faire le mal autour de soi c'est le
meilleur moyen
tôt ou tard de diriger ce mal contre
nous comme disait spinoza
tout n'est que cause et effet est très
généralement lorsque l'on s'amuse à
faire le mal autour de soi eh bien on
crée les conditions pour que ce mal nous
reviennent en pleine tête
ça n'a rien de mystique c'est une pure
loire mécaniques et physiques
action réaction fait du mal à quelqu'un
est compté car bientôt ce sera votre
tour
la relativité du mal c'est l'idée que le
mal est toujours interdépendants du bien
ce sont les deux faces de la même pièce
comme le jour a besoin de la nuit comme
la pesanteur a besoin de la légèreté et
si nous faisions un petit effort pour
constater ce qui va bien nous serions un
peu moins sensible donc
un peu moins soumis aux mâles la
conclusion de cette vidéo c'est que si
le mal existe c'est d'abord parce que
nous le laissons existe peut-être aussi
parce que nous n'avons pas la bonne
stratégie face à lui et qu'on ne vint
pas le mal en le combattant
c'est à dire en fixant notre attention
sur lui mais en vain le mal en faisant
le bien en vain le mal en nous
concentrant sur le bien merci à vous
[Musique]